so we're gonna answer the question is it
okay to drink coffee if you have a fatty
liver okay well actually coffee has a
lot of final nutrients that are
beneficial to the liver so it's not a
bad thing for Fredi liver what's bad
about coffee is non-organic coffee if
it's not organic it is filled with so
many pesticides and insecticides and
fungicides and herbicides you want to
avoid that because the liver is all
about detoxifying chemicals and we don't
want to add them back in there these
chemicals are very oxidizing which means
they increase inflammation okay and then
lead to cirrhosis now there's different
types of a fatty liver you have fatty
liver that actually comes from drinking
too much alcohol and then you have a
non-alcoholic fatty liver and there's
different types one type would be just a
fatty liver another one would be fatty
liver plus inflammation which then leads
to cirrhosis
so there's several types there's several
ways to figure out if you have a fatty
liver ultrasound biopsy which is
invasive an MRI is a lot better than a
biopsy but an ultrasound might be the
best way to determine if you have a
fatty liver or not now if you look up
information about a fatty liver it'll
say that fatty liver is one factor of
the metabolic syndrome and metabolic
syndrome or syndrome X has several
things it has high triglycerides low
good cholesterol HDL so-called good
cholesterol a central obesity visceral
fat that in your belly high blood
pressure and high blood glucose but in
reality if we add a fatty liver here all
of these are symptoms of high insulin so
if you have a fatty liver there are
things that are really important and
things that are trivial I'm gonna tell
you the most important things that fat
on your liver is not coming from eating
fat it's from eating carbohydrates and
consuming things like trans fats and
even vegetable oils like soy and corn
that's GML so the most important thing
is to reduce your carbs especially
fructose and any form the other thing
that can really help you is something
called choline you can get this as
powder choline will strip the fat off
your liver it just so happens that egg
yolks are really high in choline the
tain hydrochloride is really good for
the liver as well of stripping fat off
the liver a lot of greens as in
vegetables can help you and then of
course in a minute fasting keeps your
insulin low so your body can use the fat
off the liver as fuel so what happens
with a lot of people is that they are
consuming too many carbs they have high
blood glucose and all this glucose has
to go somewhere so it's being converted
into fat into the fat cell and there's a
point where your fat cells get so
stuffed it leaks out and it spills over
and around the fat cells and it starts
building up around the organs and so the
body will start shoving it into spaces
around the the abdominal cavity around
the viscera around the the belly and
then also in the liver as well so we
have this super saturation of fat
throughout the entire thoracic cavity
and in the cavity down here in your gut
so when you see people with a belly you
know there's also that fat on the liver
as well what's interesting is that 9 out
of 10 diabetics then are overweight have
a fatty liver why is that well because
they all have high blood glucose that's
why okay so in termina fasting very very
important vitamin E is very important
because the amount of oxidation that's
occurring with the high sugar okay so
the high sugar is very oxidative to the
arteries to the liver cells so if you
take enough high-quality natural vitamin
E that can greatly help reduce the
complications of the fatty liver and
definitely slow down the cirrhosis which
is a scar tissue because once you have
the cirrhosis very difficult to undo
that and reverse that and you pretty
much get on the liver transplant list
when that happens so the best thing to
do is to avoid that and prevent it so in
summary the liver is a really important
organ in detoxification so we don't want
to start putting more chemicals in there
do your organic coffee personally I do
coffee I do one small cup in more
alright thanks for watching if you're
liking this content please subscribe now
and I will actually keep you updated on
future videos